foreign
[Music]
hey you guys time once again for tomes
of Terror I apologize this is a little
bit later going up than usual and if
you're one of our patrons then normally
you would have been seeing it a day
early like I would usually have posted
on Sunday but unfortunately I just
didn't get around to it I was a little
bit late I didn't get the entire book
read you know in time for the video to
go up early so at least I'm getting it
up on Monday which is the day that it
would normally go up but again I'm sorry
for any uh you know inconvenience that
that might have cost I'm sure it wasn't
because it could be it's me you know
what I mean I like to get stuff up in a
timely fashion so I always feel bad when
I don't but hopefully it won't happen
again it was just the last video one of
the last videos that I did over the
weekend like took way longer than I
thought so I just didn't get enough a
chance to read but I'm doing it now so
finally so in my recent Mega post Mega
video
discussing the VHS movie franchise which
incidentally was why this video took me
longer to get to because that took like
way longer than I was expecting I
mentioned that found footage horror
wasn't really usually my go-to sub genre
uh though of course I listed a bunch of
examples of it that I did actually
really really like a lot uh
interestingly though like right around
the time that I was planning this you
know Mega video that I was doing on the
VHS franchise a friend of the show in
New York City DJ Maniac uh sent me a
Facebook message and showed me this
really cool looking new horror Anthology
Book that was just published in early
October of 2022 and it was called found
an anthology of found footage horror
stories and it was edited by Andrew call
and gabino Iglesias now aside from the
absolutely Stellar cover design which
looked like a old beat up like Memorex
videotape I mean I can really you guys
know I'm a graphic designer so if you do
like some awesome graphics and like some
cool theming and [ __ ] like that I'm
gonna be on board and just hope that the
story is good but that's absolutely
gonna get me to like want to read it I
mean the whole thing sounded like a
really neat concept though I will admit
at first that I wasn't entirely sure
like what the stories were gonna be like
like for the only thing I could think of
I was like well with found footage like
in written form would it manifest as
like you know like an epistolary novel
like Dracula or something like that or
you know would there be other variations
like what are the parameters what are we
talking about uh and happily I was able
to find out because aforementioned
friend DJ Maniac actually bought the
ebook for me so thank you very much for
that DJ Maniac much appreciated and I
finally got to read it uh over this past
weekend like I read it on Sunday and I
have to say uh again very happily this
is easily one of the most consistently
great anthologies that I have had the
pleasure of reading every single story
was great to excellent and although
obviously just like in any Anthology
some some of them you know were more my
cup of tea than others but there wasn't
a single one that I didn't think was
outstanding absolutely worth reading in
one way or another I should also note
too that my initial idea of all the
stories being essentially like maybe I
don't know like told through emails or
something like that for example was way
too limited yeah some of the stories
were told like that but this was a very
I was impressed by the variation
um of these kind of like mixed media
stories like some of them were made up
of you know for example like a series of
texts police reports handwritten
messages and so on uh some were told as
journal entries some were told as Court
depositions or video transcripts and
some were actually told in kind of like
traditional narrative style like a
regular story but had a story that
focused on some kind of found media like
as it's sort of like central theme so I
mean I was actually really pleased at
all at like the vast diversity of
formats in here and also it was cool
that they all even though they were all
really diverse and different they all
ease very easily fit within the found
footage framework like you weren't
reading some of the stories and be like
well that's a reach you know what I mean
because I kind of feel like as much as I
loved like the um Halloween anthologies
that I did like over uh toward the end
of October like in a couple of those
there were some stories in there that I
would be like well that wasn't really a
Halloween story you know what I mean but
this one I never got that like every
single one of them had a found footage
kind of thing like none of them seemed
like they didn't belong or anything like
that but they were all still really
different and the whole collection too
like I guess this isn't surprising but
it gave me like a really strong like ARG
or Creepypasta kind of vibe and that was
actually one of my favorite things about
it was again that the stories gave you
that kind of like you know mood to them
but they were all still like really
different and really stood out from one
another so the first story is called two
months too long by Holly Ray Garcia and
this one unspools as it's like a series
of increasingly alarming text messages
from a very clearly unhinged
ex-girlfriend and later on like it
starts out with a bunch of text messages
and then it's like later interspersed
with like work emails like handwritten
notes personal emails police incident
reports photos and so on
um as the aforementioned girlfriend his
name is Shonda starts to kind of
escalate her campaign of Terror against
this guy she's been dating for only two
months like hence why the story is
called two months too long
um his name is Alex by the way uh this
one was actually like a great start to
the book it really kind of like uh set
the theme established the tone and it
really kind of like immersed you right
into this very chillingly realistic
scenario which you know I've known some
people that went through some very
similar things to this and this is
pretty much how uh the kind of [ __ ]
plays out uh and it goes also towards
some like pretty gross and like dark
places at the end so yeah this was a
really good one so the next story was
Josh roundtree's face down Death volume
eight uh and this was actually laid out
as kind of like a regular story like it
was a regular narrative format but it's
centered around a young boy who was
obsessed with those kind of like real
death compilation videos that were you
know all the rage like back in the 80s
and 90s like Faces of Death being the
most popular but there were some other
knockoff Brands as well
um I really really liked this story too
because it kind of like brought back
memories of watching like really messed
up [ __ ] like all this old grotty VHS
tapes that you got like from the mom and
pop video store down the street uh back
in the day oh and I also really liked
the kind of real bizarre like somewhat
kind of Supernatural but like I said
also kind of creepypasta-esque uh
direction that this one goes in toward
the end as the maybe the reasons for
like why this boy is so fascinated with
watching these videos
um is kind of slowly revealed so yeah I
liked that as well this was also like
really creepy and the next one was
another kind of more traditionally told
story which was concerning found
videotapes and it was called Junk pickup
by Fred Fisher uh the fourth and I
really loved this one too like it's
about a kid named Peter who always goes
along with his dad on these kind of junk
picking Expeditions on weekends and on
one particular outing Peter finds this
old like military Foot Locker and it's
full of old videotapes now him and his
dad like they're really it's set in the
present day but him and his dad really
like
um kind of finding these old caches of
videotapes they have like an old VCR
like set up in the basement and it's
like so they're always they always kind
of find it like treasure you know what I
mean it's like oh we're gonna pop some
popcorn and get some sodas and we're
gonna sit down and like watch whatever
the [ __ ] is on these videotapes
um so they're really excited that they
found this one it's got this big pile in
there
um they said most of them over the years
they found her usually just kind of like
people's home movies or you know mostly
like just old music videos or you know
movies that people taped off cable like
with commercials on them [ __ ] like that
but in this batch there is actually one
of the tapes that actually has like a
bunch of old video music videos that
were taped off MTV but then at the end
like when they're watching it there's
kind of like a little bit of a clip
that's really really eerie that's kind
of like a boy that at first seems like
he's videotaping himself sleeping and he
like seems really nervous
um I won't spoil what else is on the
video but uh suffice it to say that it
is uh creepy as [ __ ] it's pretty [ __ ]
creepy and uh you know after the
protagonist like sees this video he
decides that he's going to go back to
the person you know where they bought
the videotapes from and see if he can
like unravel the mystery of like who
this boy is and uh you know things don't
go too well so the next one is called
disappearances at Coal Hill by Nick
kolakowski and this starts out as kind
of like a series of email exchanges
between a writer named Rick and his
editor whose name is Catherine and Rick
is like pitching a story that he wants
to write or like that he wants to
investigate about a series of
unexplained vanishings like in some
dense Woods like a section of dense
Woods in Virginia
um and after that kind of setup the tail
kind of then pivots to a newspaper story
and then it goes into like a string of
posts on like a subreddit which is
called Our Mysterious Mysteries where
people are kind of talking about the
missing people and speculating about
what might be going on like where they
might have gone because none of the
bodies have been found
so one of the people posting on this
subreddit lives in the area and actually
is contacted by the editor from the
first part of the story Catherine uh who
wants to go out there and like see you
know what happened like with the initial
thing and Terror ensues now I really did
like the build up of this one and the
way it kept the story like mostly
grounded in reality until the end and
then it went into more I guess like an
ambiguous Direction a little bit I think
the best thing about this one actually
was the way it left a lot of things to
kind of be filled in by the reader which
is exactly how a story like this would
kind of unfold in real life as different
people with different bits of
information would all be trying to put
together the pieces to a puzzle that
nobody really knows the whole entire
answer to so the next story was called
the veiled Lady by Angela sylvain and
that was told as a series of diary
entries from this woman who has just
woken up from a 14-month coma and is
writing about her experiences in order
to try to like trigger her memories from
before the coma like to come back like
her doctors told her to do that because
she doesn't have a lot of memory or just
fragmentary memories of what happened
before she went into the coma or before
like the accident or whatever it was uh
this story was actually very compelling
and very cleverly constructed as the
narrator may or may not be reliable
because of her injuries that's all I'm
gonna say and you kind of think the
story is going one way but then it goes
kind of in a direction that you may not
be expecting which I actually wasn't
expecting so I really liked the surprise
of it this one was actually like a
really good thriller and would probably
make like a cool movie actually like a
lot of these stories would actually make
really good movies now that I'm thinking
about it I mean I really did like them
in written form and it was kind of cool
that they were like I said found footage
or mixed media some of these wouldn't
even have to be found footage in movie
form and they would still be good I mean
it might help but but this one I've kind
of felt like would make like a really
good like classical type of Thriller so
the next story The spew of news by Clay
McLeod Chapman uh this one was the kind
of the most grimly funny of the bunch I
guess and will probably be uh pretty
relatable to a great number of people
that's what I'm gonna say basically it's
about this guy whose elderly parents
like start to change drastically after
continually watching a news channel
called Fox News Fox and I was like that
made me laugh so hard uh which promises
just the facts fax and basically
broadcast I mean you probably know where
this is going but it broadcasts nothing
but like fear-mongering and outrage
fodder you know much much like uh some
real ones so the narrator has tried to
reason with his parents but they keep
slipping like further and further into
this angry little conspiracy-laden World
um he finally gets really worried about
them because he doesn't like hear from
them for several days and at first he
just kind of thinks oh well they're just
being [ __ ] and they don't want to
talk to me because I'm trying to like
you know talk to them and reason with
them and they're mad at me but after a
while he starts to get really really
worried he's like yeah they're really
not answering their phone so I really
have to like drive down there and see
because he lives like 200 miles away or
something so he's like I really have to
drive down there and uh see what's going
on with them and uh so he goes to check
on them and uh let's just say it doesn't
end all that well uh this one was
actually very
um very topical like I said and would
have been hilarious if it wasn't so
painfully sad I kind of found it really
sad but also like really kind of like
blackly comic at the same time so then
the next one was called Joe Butler's
ghost uh was Joe Butler's Ghost Town
adventures and that's very much like a
classic sort of Creepypasta tale and
it's told as a series of like
descriptions of unsettling videos and in
particular like one unsettling video
that was posted on a YouTube channel
that was kind of like an exploring
abandoned places type of uh Channel now
whoever is writing the descriptions is
speculating about the final video that
was posted on the channel which was only
titled help but h-e-l-l-p in which this
abandoned supposedly abandoned town that
whoever is filming the video is
exploring sometimes
um they're sometimes like flashes of it
like changing in ways that I won't spoil
like I said so this was another really
solid tale that kind of leaves the
reader to fill in the blanks and it's
really really spooky like because it
leaves so much to your imagination so
the shortest story in the collection was
called regular Saint by Donna Lynch and
this one's formatted the way it's format
is almost like a poem like a free like a
free verse or something like that
um or kind of like as a series of it's
kind of like a chain of these very very
terse messages that seem like they're
being just put out there or exchanged
between several girls whose names are
all Mary like it's Mary L Marianne
versus Mary C or something like that at
a religious school like a private school
they're talking about a classmate named
Jeannie who uploaded a mysterious video
having something to do with praying to
Saint dymphna uh this one was a little
bit I'm gonna say it's a little bit
inscrutable and it kind of left a lot to
your imagination but one thing that was
kind of cool about it is that it really
encouraged you to go like investigate
the specifics about the saint because it
is a real Saint uh to figure out what
happened in the story because it doesn't
tell you you basically have to like go
to like outside things to like figure
out to read between the lines
essentially so the next one was called
walls and floors and bricks and stone by
Georgia cook and that one also kind of
started out as as email exchanges and
autopsy transcripts like between two
Pathologists and they're looking into
this really bizarre case where this
entire family died in a newly built
house like they had just lived there for
like a few weeks or something and all
the bodies had some weird unexplained
thing like going on with them like the
mom has like house breaks in her stomach
even though there's no way that they
possibly have gotten in there like their
whole uh you know one of the guys has
like pipe like growing out of his head
or something like that
um this one was actually like a lot of
fun too it's it came across a little bit
like a mashup between the autopsy of
Jane Doe that 2016 movie and um the
Brian asman novel which I reviewed like
on here a long time ago which is called
man [ __ ] this house if you've read that
one
um it was kind of like a combination of
like the best things about both of those
but with its own kind of spin on it too
but yeah like the whole concept like
really pulled you right into the mystery
like so this lady has like bricks in her
stomach and I can't figure out how they
got in there so it's like immediately we
were I was just kind of like oh tell me
more you know what I mean so yeah it was
really good so the next one is called
summons and that was written by Ali
Wilkes and it's told as a sort of like a
deposition type thing
um at a panel it's like a fitness to
practice panel so there's like a social
worker named Miss Arnold and she's kind
of been brought before this committee to
answer charges about a girl that had
been under her care whose name was Emily
Rook uh whose parents have some
interesting relay religious practices
let's call it that so I actually like
this one because while it's quite clear
to the reader from Miss Arnold's
descriptions
um you know you know what's going on but
Miss Arnold herself like the character
is kind of like clueless and naive and
so she's like really oblivious to like
what's happening before her eyes so it
kind of like generates suspense in that
way but yeah this was also a really good
one these were all good stories I mean
you know I mean like every single one of
them is good so so uh even though I just
said that like one of my favorites in
the book like I said it's kind of like
hard to pick because they were all like
really good
um but one of my favorites in the book
was actually called Green Magnetic Tape
by Tim McGregor and this story which is
actually structured not you know not so
much mixed media but was structured like
a traditional story
um but the narrator is decluttering the
garage and he comes across a set of old
videotapes of uh Jenny who is his
girlfriend of five years now he's always
known Jenny as is a very straight arrow
young woman she doesn't drink she only
eats organic food she's very very tidy
and organized she's just one of those
very potential like into fitness and
diet and health and all that kind of
stuff she's very much that kind of
person but uh the version of Jenny that
he sees on these tapes is another type
of person entirely and he starts to
become obsessed with the DraStic
difference between her past and present
selves so this was actually like kind of
a really really good psychological
Horror Story about the breakdown of
trust in a relationship and the idea
that you can never really know another
person like as well as you might think
the next one is called accidents of a
sort by Kurt Favre and this is also fun
and also like pretty bizarre but I
really dug it uh it actually at the end
it kind of goes a little bit in a
metaphysical kind of Direction it's
basically about two guys like one older
guy one younger guy who work at an
insurance agency and what they do is
they study the aftermath of car
accidents like to determine fault like
if there's video they look at that or if
there's like police reports or whatever
they're trying to figure out like you
know how much the insurance company
should pay out or whatever
so while the older guy whose name is
vayne um he's kind of like seen it all
and he's really jaded at this point the
younger narrator is still kind of a noob
and sort of like the gruesomeness and
just ultimate Randomness and
meaninglessness of these accidents that
he's analyzing are is still like really
begin is still like affects him a lot so
he asks vayne one night like out of
curiosity it's like isn't there anything
that you've ever seen like on the job
that keeps you up at night because he
seems so unaffected by everything uh at
that point vayne very reluctantly shows
him uh a pretty [ __ ] up video which
I'm not gonna say what's on it but I
will say that it's of a seemingly
impossible occurrence and uh the
narrator like after that like can't get
out of his head so this one yeah was
like an excellent excellent premise and
it kind of became across as like a
little bit like profound and kind of
like really thought-provoking like the
way it was resolved like I said it
almost kind of goes like in a weird like
metaphysical I don't want to say like
what it reminded me of because is that
will kind of spoil it but I'll just say
it's like metaphysical that's what I'm
going to say it kind of goes in that
direction a little bit and it really did
kind of like make you think along those
lines so then there's a story by Bev
Vincent which is called a grave issue
and this actually deals with one of my
very favorite horror tropes which is
like cursed media uh in this case it's a
supposedly lost book by kind of a
well-known author who has passed away
whose name is Ramsay edwinson now the
story is actually told as a string of
posts on an author fan forum and it kind
of tells about one poster on this forum
and they find like a brand new copy of a
previously unknown book by this author
at a yard sale and they're kind of
trying to determine like whether it's
authentic or not but it soon starts to
become obvious that the book is possibly
cursed so like many of the Other Stories
the fun of this one kind of lies in what
isn't revealed and what connections that
the reader has to make you know
themselves which I think is kind of like
the appeal of these type of so-called
found footage stories like in general
because I mean in real life they almost
never have clear-cut resolution so like
a lot of the fun of it is like coming up
with your own theories and stuff like
that so this one kind of had that vibe
to it too like a lot of the stories in
this had that and I thought was like
really appealing to me so the next one
was the Novak Roadhouse Massacre by Alan
Baxter and this one is formatted as a
bunch of like police incident reports
and transcripts of dash cam footage
which is concerning the supposed Rampage
of a purported vicious serial killer uh
who is suspected to be a man named
Carlton Davies but as the story goes on
uh the reader starts to realize that
maybe uh the Killer is not this guy and
is maybe perhaps not even Human After
All and that there might be some kind of
creature uh roaming through the Wilds of
Australia because this is actually set
in Australia's story now another one of
the best stories in the book in my
opinion was one called uh Robert Levy
and it was called this video is
unavailable and this one is laid out as
kind of like an oral history type
magazine story about uh what they call
and this is a quote one of the darkest
episodes born of the internet age so
it's basically like Snippets of
interviews with people that were
involved in this particular incident so
we're learning about this very a
well-known Beauty YouTuber whose name
was Daniel Travers and he ended up
garnering like this really passionate
fan following with his you know they say
his personality was very genuine and he
was very fearless and like being himself
and like doing his thing but
um over the course of him having like a
channel his fans start to notice like a
change in him as the videos go on and
they start to fear that something maybe
something bad and possibly even like
Supernatural is maybe happening to him
so after they attempt to get help from
in more like traditional ways like you
know calling the police in whatever City
he lives in and like trying to do
welfare checks and stuff
um that doesn't really work out so they
decide to take matters into their own
hands quite literally as it turns out uh
and this one actually ends up being a
very very Grim kind of tragic story
about I guess about like obsessive
fandom and good intentions gone horribly
wrong and the thing of I think the scary
thing about this one was that while it
was exaggerated in places it wasn't that
exaggerated and it does seem like
something that could actually happen
which made it like a lot more sad and a
lot more scary so the next one dear
Penny by Jeremy Hepler was another kind
of classic you don't know your loved
ones as well as you think you do story
and it has to do with this very strict
uptight super religious um and also kind
of like a little bit delusional uh mom
whose name is Cheryl and she discovers
the hidden Diary of her daughter Maura
which is concealed in the innards of
this big big huge stuffed panda bear
named Penny that's why it's called dear
penny so while Cheryl was always under
the impression that her daughter was
this like perfect angel she was like
this cheerleader and she was really good
at school and she really loved going to
church and blah blah the diary ends up
demonstrating that everything she
thought that she knew about Maura was
basically just this very carefully
calculated facade like that she's not
really like that at all this is another
one that I think would make a really
very gripping movie to be honest though
as I said I think most of these
absolutely would but this one like I
said I guess because it's more like a
classic Thriller and I really liked that
aspect of it and the next story was
called the Paul and that's by Aristo
couveras uh hopefully I'm pronouncing
that sort of correctly this one actually
goes in somewhat of like a kind of a
cosmic horror Direction
um and it's sort of like positing a kind
of like an Annihilation style anomaly
which is like hovering in the Skies over
the Indian Ocean that may or may not
have something to do with the real and
kind of weird Interstellar object
which in the universe of the story is
either is possibly sent by intelligent
beings but maybe not for the reasons
that we might be suspecting that's all
I'm gonna say uh so yeah this was like a
very creepy like lovecraftian type of
story like I said if you like
Annihilation you might get into this one
as well because it's it's not similar
similar but it's like I don't know the
theme is kind of similar
um it's kind of just about like forces
much greater than like humans can
understand so like I said a lot more
Cosmic horror the most Cosmic horror out
of all out of the bunch so yet another
one of my very favorites in this
collection uh I had a lot of favorites
in this as you uh can tell was the last
story which is by um Ali CA hopefully
I'm kind of pronouncing that right I'm
just I'm terrible with pronouncing names
you guys uh but it was called like a
small hand-built house and this one was
also kind of structured structured like
a regular story but was you know very
very effective very well told the
narrator is this recent Widow named
Hazel and she basically uh she had a
husband uh who she'd been married to for
52 years and his name was Parker and
he's died recently obviously that that's
why she's a widow now many years before
Parker had built this little house like
out in the garden like a little man cave
type situation uh you know before they
would call it a man cave but now they
would call it a man cave
um so it's a kind of a place that he
would go to to like be alone when he
wanted to get away from her Hazel never
really minded it because you know she
kind of had her own [ __ ] going on her
own hobbies and she's just like yeah
whatever just get the hell out of here
and do your own thing whatever just
leave me alone so she was never really
all that curious as to what exactly he
was doing out there but one day not too
long after his death she's in the little
house looking for something like a
flashlight or a tool or something that
he think that she thinks was out there
and while she's out there she finds a
videotape that Parker left for her that
sends her on a pretty horrifying
scavenger hunt that also has a pretty
definite time limit that's what I'm
gonna say uh this one was again a very
classic story about how you can be
married to someone for half a century
for example and not know Jack about them
but but the way it unfolded was like
really really entertaining and I think
like the characterization of Hazel was
so appealing that I was kind of like
immediately sucked into the story even
though it doesn't go in like any it
doesn't have like any big huge twists or
anything like that but it's just like
really laid out really well and the
characterization is good so it's just
like keeps you interested and like I
said there's also kind of like a time
limit aspect to it as well so that like
generates a lot of suspense so I mean if
you're at all into found footage movies
args Creepypasta style stories I would
not hesitate to recommend this Anthology
every single story in it is absolutely
worth reading and while they do all
adhere to like a found footage or mixed
media type of theme there's actually
like a lot of variety a surprising
amount of variety like within those
parameters so I mean there will
definitely be something for everybody
um it's kind of like rare to come across
an anthology as really consistently
excellent as this one is so I'm gonna
give like major props to the editors and
all the authors involved and also a
special mention to the cover designer
who actually like sold me on the concept
like within a couple of seconds of like
seeing it
um but yeah this was just like a really
well put together package and it gave me
a really spooky good time and I'm kind
of I'm really really glad also that DJ
Maniac bought it for me because now I
can like go back and read it again like
in a few months because I absolutely do
want to reread it and revisit it at some
point in the future so that'll do it for
this installment of tomes of Terror and
I'll see you guys again on the next one
bye